people of the internet retrorecontour
here and today we're talking all
about when we might see more news more
details more
something more anything on hogwarts
legacy
unfortunately e3 and also the summer
games fest are now
in the rearview mirror and as you guys
already know by now absolutely no
hogwarts legacy news whatsoever so the
question
now becomes when will we get
more information on this game guys the
last thing we heard in an official
capacity of course was about the delay
then a few months ago jason keller the
ceo of warner media tweeted out some
concept art images
and that has been it guys it has been
slim pickings around here when it comes
to hogwarts legacy news and content for
us to discuss here what else would you
like for me to cover and talk about here
on the channel in the meantime whether
it's hogwarts legacy related or
something else now when it comes to win
slash where we might hear more about
hogwarts lexi next i think there's a
good possibility and then i think
there's
a bad possibility so let's go ahead and
get the bad one out of the way first and
i think the bad one would be that we
don't hear anything about hogwarts
legacy for
the rest of the year it's hard to
believe man we are already in
june guys june 2021 at least at the time
of recording this you may be watching
this months later who knows years later
but right now june 2021 already halfway
through this year and i know a lot of us
when they
delayed it so early in 2021 we're like
okay does this mean it might be
early 2022. in the back of my mind i
just went ahead and said
you know what i'm assuming it's going to
be holiday 2022. and so if you assume
that then it kind of makes sense there
there is that chance that we could go
all of 2021 without getting anything at
all about this game
which i know i know trust me i hear you
i feel you guys that would truly be
frustrating for us
not to get anything and i want to be
clear here because i could see for
someone new to the channel you might
come in and think oh i'm complaining i
want them to just show everything show
gameplay
no nothing like that at all i mean don't
get me wrong gameplay would be
great at this point but honestly what
i'm looking for is just kind of a slow
trickle of information here a couple
screenshots one month
the next month maybe we have a dev
interview the next month maybe they
highlight a certain mechanic in the game
the next month maybe we get a trailer i
mean just you know
little slow trickle of information
as we get closer to launch now when i
say that phrase right there then you
might think well maybe it's not
close to launch which i know is not what
any of us want to think about
right now now i said that was the bad
one i said there's also a good one
in my opinion the good outcome here and
the good
possibility would be if hogwarts legacy
shows up
at sony's event what is sony's event you
say well
trust me sony is almost certainly going
to have some type of event
most likely here in the next couple of
weeks highlighting what
they're going to be doing for the rest
of 2021 and maybe some things in 2022 as
well
heavy rumor right now is that a new god
of war trailer will be shown and of
course we already know that has been
delayed and pushed out to 2022
but there is no way that sony is going
to remain completely
silent i mean playstation has to say
something after nintendo just had all
their announcements microsoft had a
really solid showing at e3
playstation is currently the market
leader right now
in the console space i guess technically
not really if you consider the switch
but then
again where does the switch really fall
in terms of console generations anyway
i don't know however you want to look at
it playstation is doing very well right
now so they're not
just going to sit this one out
completely they didn't go to e3 they
didn't do anything for summer games fest
but they almost certainly have some
announcements in store and as we've seen
in recent history with sony
they've kind of like to do their own
events now why would hogwarts legacy
appear at a playstation event well if
you remember back
in 2020 back in september at that
playstation event
when they did the big blowout of the ps5
that is where we saw
hogwarts legacy in an official capacity
that is for the first time
in fact it led to a lot of speculation
at first there were a lot of people on
youtube saying hey is this game
exclusive to ps5 they were a little
confused because it was shown there
no it's not exclusive to ps5 or even ps4
it's gonna be on xbox it's gonna be on
pc so you don't have to worry there
but what i do think this has the
potential to mean is that perhaps sony
has some sort of marketing exclusivity
deal with
wb4 hogwarts legacy and if that's
the case then i think hogwarts legacy
would be a very good candidate to be
shown
at this sony playstation event that i
think is going to happen here in the
next few weeks but then that takes us to
the ultimate question here
do they have anything to show if they
don't have anything new to show then
there's
probably not going to be a new trailer i
don't think they would force them to
show something there
but i think at this point there has to
be something
new that they can show again even if
it's not a specific trailer maybe they
do another playstation blog post where
they answer some questions about the
game
if it doesn't show up at the playstation
event there are a couple of other events
throughout the rest of the year like
gamescom but i don't really consider any
of those being
incredibly likely the one other event
where i could see there being a slim
chance is with the 2021 game awards we
talked a lot about the 2020 game awards
here on this channel and the chances of
hey maybe hogwarts legacy will be there
there was that tweet from jeff keely and
the little trailer from keeley that had
a
slight glimpse of the original hogwarts
legacy trailer in it
which made people think oh it's gonna be
here in some capacity at the game awards
we're gonna get something new
unfortunately that didn't happen and
then what a month later or so we got
news that had been delayed
all the way a full year at least a full
year into 2022
and so that is where we stand here today
trust me i'm right there with you guys
i'm i'm waiting i'm looking i'm
constantly scouring the internet for
information on this game so if something
new
comes out you guys know just where to
find it
youtube.com retrorecontour now if you're
new here i have a full
hogwarts legacy playlist of all the news
that has been discussed so far you can
check that out here on the right side of
your screen
maybe you're in the mood for some let's
plays you can check out my old school
harry potter let's plays here on the
left side of your screen i'm currently
replaying all of the harry potter
console games
having a lot of fun as always thank you
all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon